qu'est le conseil de classe de ce2 je
sais que vous adorez les conseils de
classe aussi vos noté benjamin castaldi
bien sûr est partie et c'est parti pour
le conseil de classe du turbulent
castaldi un élève au parcours en dents
de scie mais qui a toujours fait valoir
son éducation impeccable et son amour du
chic à la française et je me brosse est
intégralement la nuit non non non
benjamin castaldi c'est aussi un
séducteur hors pair qui collectionne les
mariages fait tatouer le prénom de la
femme sur l'avant bras
c'est là qu'elle alors qu'à renverser
c'est qu'on a tous les trois la même
passion qui nous anime
vous parlez la danse la wii c'est pas
les mariages comme toi et parfois qu'on
caste à part l'on n'entend pas toujours
tout ça vous savez à qui appartient ce
choc est alors ma part les biens forme
je me suis couché assez vite
d'accord vous êtes vous êtes en
bibliothèque en mode vidéo donne en fait
et tout va bien c'est toi qui parles je
sais pas comment il a fait pour animer
des émissions on dirait vous savez les
gars qui sont au fond de la bouteille
mais l'élève castaldi a aussi été
victime de ses autres camarades comme
toutes ces fois où ils ont balancé son
numéro de téléphone en direct le numéro
de joseba sa fille
bref casta en résumé benjamin castaldi
se son côté de tat alors valérie bénaïm
vous êtes à côté de lui je sais que vous
ne pouvez pas le sentir mais forcément
bus qui sort de lui
vous êtes obligé alors écoutez justement
à ce propos je voulais souligner les
efforts les wii les progrès les efforts
faits au niveau du transit intestinal
benjamin bon c'est vrai il peut être
beaucoup moins cette année alors ben ça
sera en lettres d'or tient les gens qui
nous rejoignent
oui c'est l'info du jour mais croyez moi
parce que j'adorais que jean marc
morandini fasse une jama kazadi peut
être beaucoup moins que l'année dernière
vous vous prenez à la rigolade mais moi
qui suis à côté de lui je me cache pas
que ça embellit mon année ah bah oui
quand même s'est il a quelques petits
défauts tout de même il est très soupe
au lait il part très vite au quart de
tour
oui il a une propension à vouloir tout
le temps se battre avec vous je lui
redis benjamin arrête de vouloir te
battre avec cyril il est plus forte mais
oui voilà non les plus teigneux
il est plus un art mieux et plus méchant
plus méchant donc alors voilà arrête
mais c'est parce que je l'aimais et gpg
jurés je vous le dis 1 devant tout le
monde
je ne ferai plus jamais maman mais même
s'il me tape même dans les loges vrai tu
l'as vu cela qu'à dix minutes même s'il
me tard il a juré dans notre lancée pour
lui dire que c'est la dernière
s'emporte mais il fait des progrès au
moins attention à ton numéro de
téléphone parce que c'est après 60 quand
même et cinéma record 1 34e
non je donnerais pas là dedans bon sinon
à part ça excellent camarade jacquard et
puis j'attends depuis tf1 depuis 20 ans
quand même ces imposteurs il y les
bouquins des invités de d'argent ils
regardent les films des invités
immédiate surtout à l'afrique connaît
tout le monde dans le métier donc être
macération pour l'émission et c'est un
très bon camarade donc pour tout ça je
donne un excellent mais moi en plus mine
de rien toi tu es sûr que tu regardais
castaldi à la télé ouais moi ça me fait
bizarre de faire le conseil de classe de
2de benjamin c'est une [ __ ] c'est un
grand monsieur
je dispute alors écrit je suis là à
parler de benjamin castaldi alors que
quand je suis arrivé dans l'émission je
suis avec tin d'à priori parce que les
gens dehors me disent ils il alerte les
l'air d'être une tête de con castaldi
qui commet il est dans la vie des gens
le connaissaient mais je suis à des gens
dit ça et je dis je sais pas au début je
sais pas et tout doucement je me suis
aperçu que un peu comment il parle pas
beaucoup
moi je me demande ce que je fais là
parfois lui c'est ce qui fait parce que
quand il ya des sujets graves
il est là y poids parole et il a
toujours des prises de position c'est
carré ses prises de position donc je
vais pas je vais pas en faire des tonnes
et des tonnes
moi j'adore benjamin il a été là j'ai pu
apercevoir ces derniers mois que c'était
un bonhomme quand il a fait se lever
pour faire le bon ami s'est levé il a
fait le bonhomme
et ça pour moi ça compte beaucoup plus
pour faire mille ans benjamin j't'adore
je te mets à 8
bravo
j'ai envie chez le maire ah oui ça fait
3 je suis là ça prend c'est vrai j'en
rigolais mais les yeux les plus petits
rhumes et ce à quoi rigoler je vois très
bien mais ça continue c'est quand
l'opération le 21 juin
non j'y vais le but est le 20 juin j'ai
vu le 20 juin
c'est la dernière de tp fait garde temps
je consulte de vent à vous consulter le
vin web cette gaffe aussi finir je vois
la regarder alors donc ça fait trois ans
que telle à peu près je crois trop
quatre ans je sais plus a fait le temps
le temps file à une vitesse
mes aïeux voilà et quand tu arrives et
c'est vrai qu'on s'est dit on avec
benjamin on avait une vraie bête qui
arrivait au tour natale et c'est vrai tu
as été une vraie bête je reconnais cng
pour une qualité et une vraie bête de
scène alors quelle bête on s'attendait à
lyon c'est vrai que war on nous avait
vanté sa en tout cas nous est promis sa
vie ton parcours à tf1 et m6
malheureusement on a eu un putois il a
collé après on s'est dit heureux c'est
vrai qu'ils sont un peu mauvais mais au
moins il parle bien c'est vrai que sa
vraie perroquet la voirie l'aï la
flamboyance été bon contre en ressources
d'une carte
je me demande si vous n'êtes pas
meilleur que vous bossez pas
cette façon on connaît tous et celle du
bas c'est quoi ces pains etc dont
évidemment c'est une troupe 1 voilà on a
compris et elle aurait fait le bien
alors ah bah oui c'est vous qui m'avez
ça va pas ça là bas fait la dernière
bien alors d'oeil sur cette voie là
depuis peu il nous fait croire qu'à un
taureau un combattant qui veut vous
affronter tous les jours sur le ring
l'anneau en fait c'est un chihuahua un
chihuahua plus une cas plus une taupe
je conçois 3 c'est très bien payé
ces gourous les tailles il a travaillé
le garde au nom de au nom d'une pipe à
guam juste dernier trimestre
comme anna est assez toutes ces missions
khaleeji mohamed
je vais commencer par le point faible
qui à mon sens est le plus grave
l'adhésion vous provoquez souvent cyril
mais vous n'allez jamais au bout au
final toujours une façon de se dégonfler
ne pas aller au combat alors que j'ai
entendu des octogone des choses comme ça
mais je pense qu'on aura rien du tout et
le point fort c'est que je pense que
vous êtes le l'animateur le chroniqueur
qui a le meilleur ratio nombre de mots
salé rabat à ces mêmes avoir une
émission où finalement vous pétez plus
que vous ne parlez pas de madame ka di
bello colin vaines des jets d'eau glacée
engine joyon oman jouer ça rime avec
couilles en or mais c'est bon avec pas
de quick elle lourdeur à l'école j'ai
deux points positifs de points négatifs
alors les positif c'est que quand je
sais pas où dormir je dors chez toi
le deuxième point positif on nous
regarde
dragin cassany siennes nous regarde bah
écoute mais qui sait que je baille là
vous le saviez ça n'a pas dû et le
deuxième point positif c'est que c'est
un petit peu grâce à toi que je suis ici
ce soir
ouais le point négatif c'est vrai une
fois lui qui m'a présenté vraie vie il
m'a montré une vidéo mais pas du tout
enfin on allait faire ouais et j'ai vu
julie bastien bady lui qu'elle m'appelle
à l'arrivée voilà et elle m'a appelé
d'ailleurs mais je faisais c'était cool
elle est nulle ce d'histoire de point
négatif c'est à chaque fois que j'arrive
ici à la factory je ne peux pas
m'asseoir sur la cuvette parce que tu
fais pipi partout sur les cuvettes des
femmes
non ça n'a rien à voir avec les risques
quand même abbassi basculé quand vous
voulez qu'ils puissent bien ivoirien
puis elle s'est suicidée cause de ma
bible nous allons juan david ross nous
on a une grande cuve est lui le gars il
va sans dire à mes frères il sait pas où
il va tenter d'abuser dans la loge sexe
et l étoile avec chypre et tout ça à la
porte ouverte et tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs il s'est fait pipi pas un sur
le caleçon enfin bref et le deuxième
point vous êtes très proche
sebha est le deuxième point négatif
c'est quand une peine dans la tête
donc vous faire la moyenne jimmy 5 non
ils vont paître dans la tête
tout ça c'est très sympa de votre
relation en revanche c'est propre c'est
bien qu'on aime aller à ouais c'est
horrible y aller et on l'est on va
réveiller mamie c'est vrai qu'ils
puissent en arrosage de jardins
jamal le seul homme qui a plus de
poitrine que moi malgré son régime
en benjamins c'est le groupe et sur gaza
ni quand mais nous avons envie de perdre
si les données parce que j'étais un peu
plus c'était un peu plus dur que les
autres mois donc bah c'est bien la
première fois que ça nous arrive ce week
end
jama que j'aime beaucoup c'est un besoin
c'est le conseil de classe de ce1 parce
qu'on dit tout cas sept ans on a réglé
tous ses problèmes dit pia avec papa
maman et vous parlez pipi caca popo et
tout le tout le temps oui of me dis
qu'il ya définitivement des choses comme
pas changé ps et on en a trois battre et
vous cyril il vous envoie un coup comme
ça et vous vous continuez à envoyer les
membres dans tous le sens on sait pas
pourquoi alors que c'est si facile
d'aller directement droit au but
néanmoins malgré tout ça je vous aime
profondément et pour vous je vous ai mis
on parle pas beaucoup médias avec si
j'avais 10 ans c'est sa collègue m il
prend d'état dit moi je vais là-bas
alors ou trois points bêtement alors en
trois mois la note tout à l'heure le
point faible c'est que il n'a pas
suffisamment
d'abord il suffisamment fort et
suffisamment non plus d'ailleurs dans
une émission et je remarque que même
lorsqu'il connaît des informations qu'il
a des bases analyse ne le dit pas
forcément
donc ça c'est le point faible non mais
c'est vrai et en point positif c'est que
c'est un bon camarade fidel joueurs il
est donné il a de très bonnes analyses
voilà donc pour tous à eau
abbassi justement le peu de fois où il
parle c'est toujours très ciselée et
très très pointues pour tous à fumer un
bon 8 sur 10 gyneco dac
moi si tu mettrais comme note mais
serait pas beau c'est faux que les
toreros saria bon teint teint est foutu
si mais on avait dit que si je voulais
dire quelque chose de bien il fallait
pas que j'étais remise d'ici là leurs
bâtiments j'ai vu que c'est l inverse
personne a dit quelque chose de mal non
at on appris de l'avocat star et disent
que tu vas d'axé sud mois tandis que tu
m'as puis on verra quand on comprend qu
est ce que je dirais pas que tu penses
de lui attend j'appelle roja l'impasse
qui pardonne pas non mais sinon oui
ça m'aide bien aimé ça il est plutôt
sympa il travaille bien et bon c'est un
animateur professionnel il serait le
regarde regarde apprends-moi quelques
trucs j'ai envie de savoir animer une
fois dans ma vie
j'aimerais on va co animé quelque chose
en regard portes tu voudrais animé
l'émission ajouté n'ont jamais de la vie
c'est ça pour rire
j'apprends avec vous je rêvais mais quel
rapport avec cette personne
les animateurs il est un peu plus
animateur que nous bien sûr oui mais
mais qu est ce une caméra cachée ou quoi
quand comment tu le trouves comment tu
te trouves en tant qu'animateur ici
avant-hier parce qu'il est assis comme
ça au milieu je les trouve que c'est
quelqu'un je trouve que c'est un pro et
que et bien j'aimerais que je suis pas
permet lui d'accéder je sais pas une
émission de son envergure
alameda proverbe annoot m'attendais la
note dit t'as qu'à dire quoi comment il
dire est ce que tu dis ça c'est sûr du
ca les dix thèmes parfois un peu seul
mais quitte à me dise il est bourré bon
là moi je n'ai pas mauvais a pas du tout
non non il est pas du tout à l'arrivée
un bébé n'allait pas et à ce que vous
voulez les bambous renonce à voir s'il
est vraiment pourri il faut passer comme
ça il faut battre pour être une épouse
ça va mourir doc
super merci c'est sympa d'être venu
maintenant je suis là bas mais je veux
aller
on y va non on fait vite parce que moi
j'aime beaucoup je parle avec le coeur
la carrière et comme tes yeux
elle diminue doucement au c'est moche
c'est beau jeu puis c'est pas ses yeux
qui diminue une fois c'est quoi non mais
rien pour tibet alors non dans les
points forts pour de vrai extrêmement
sympathique awa toujours de bonne humeur
ah ouais tu fais tout tout tout tout ce
qu'on te demande tu fais en reine des
neiges en ce que tu veux na na na na
voilà les missions a aussi permis de
révéler aussi sexuellement et ça s'est
très très bien
on sait très bien que dans cette
émission il n'y a pas de filtre et tout
ça on est on est tous ceux qui ont dit
ça fait très bien voilà ensuite dans tes
points faibles
quand tu parles tu prêt du cru tu parles
on ne comprend pas il est vrai que tu
arrives à ouvrir ta bouche autant que
ton voilà ce qui est plus bas qu tu
parles on ne comprend pas ce que tu dis
mais bon peut-être que c'est bien du
cours ne sera jamais donc bah oui c'est
important
daffé une bonne émission comme cette
année c'était comme j'aime ce que j'ai
vu quand j'aurai pris se sont enlevés au
large de la crète
mais comme je note comme je ne note pas
le talent mais l'application
moi je t'invite seulement regarder série
le temps en temps la télévision ou moi
qui m'occupais garde pas de talent ce
n'est pas grave
en revanche ballon peut se renseigner et
donc je te mets un 7 sur bravo
je vais vous dire moi je suis fan de
benjamin a heureusement c'est là
heureusement qu'il est là même avec moi
dans les loges avant l'émission et mine
de rien c'est un petit peu mon binôme 1
dans l'émission c'est un petit peu c'est
vrai cc voilà c'est fait et j'ai besoin
de lui et je l'aimais énormément il le
sait et c'est que serai toujours là pour
lui et l'année prochaine je peux lui
confirmer non il fera les vendredis et
je lui dis franchement il a été
excellent tous les vendredis je me
surprends même à regarder l'émission
non mais c'est vrai je regarde
l'émission avec plaisir et benjamin tu
as été formidable mon chéri vraiment je
te lis est vraiment une bombe de mecs on
sait qu'on peut compter sur toi comme
d'azemmour y est ce que toi tu es tu as
passé une belle année excellent
d'ailleurs j'ai un scoop je digère simon
contre 1 vendredi
non je suis de suite réussi vous le
savez je m'amuse beaucoup et c'est vrai
que c'est quoi dire mais c'est une
famille même si elles ont été parfois
sûrement de s'embrouiller de s'engueuler
c'est vrai que je parle pas beaucoup et
je vous rajoute où vous confier quelque
chose en fait moi je suis à cette place
là et essayer c'est très bien je veux
dire des choses moi je suis
contrairement à vous faria certains très
disciplinés cissé me donne pas la parole
je ne la prends jamais parce que je suis
à son service et cela pour l'émission il
pas pour me servir mois donc si une
série de me tend pas la main je prends
jamais la parole donc pas compte 600
couverts par les plus il sait ce qu'il a
à faire il donne la parole et serra très
bien sa durée pour prendre le ballon et
mbappé attend qu'il fasse la passe et
c'est donc assez pour répondre et après
sur leur s écoute et voilà je suis très
heureux j'ai passé quatre ans magnifique
c'est vrai que j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses même le vendredi malgré les
nombreuses années que j'ai fait à la
télévision j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses à travailler
son fils et son promoteur avec une
équipe en argent avec moins d'argent et
c'est vrai que c'est très agréable et
que et que l'on se bat et que c'est vrai
que je suis très heureux ici et
franchement et pays pour aller pour les
rideaux et tous les jours c'est quand
même un luxe c'est un privilège que on
devrait tous les jours ce remercie dieu
de la mort
en avant les notes de blues en alava les
notes de belgique mais plutôt 7,92 la
90e la note est aussi excellente note
il prend la tête du classement jama